da kannst du mit nichts anderem fahren
da bist du dann zu hause eingeschlossen
was ist denn dann der spd ist das
arschgeweih von wem auch immer ich sehe
dich nicht im bus
kommt drauf haben wir noch drin sitzen
wir nicht träumen das ist autofrei geht
dann machen wir auch nichts das ist noch
nicht mal böser wille ist kann kein
mensch bezahlt
ich gehe hier als deckel und halten
heraus wenn du so weiter machst
wenn den deutschen 1 heilig ist dann ist
es ihr auto doch es gibt streit beim
kulturgut pkw tempolimit und umweltzone
oder weiterhin freie fahrt für freie
bürger ist das auto der fluch des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts oder
bleibt es die chance auf freie
individuelle mobilität auf meiner couch
sitzen zwei die das ganz unterschiedlich
sehen
[Musik]
clinton ist einer der köpfe des avd es
also eines sehr bekannten und sehr alten
ich glaube sogar der älteste
automobilclub in deutschland
ja ich bin sicherlich sehr geprägt von
zu hause was das thema automobil
betrifft so war natürlich mein erstes
fahrzeug kann ich ja ganz absagen ein
opel gt e und das ging relativ schnell
rasant weiter nach oben
katja diehl ist eine bloggerin und
aktivistin die sich zum thema die
mobilität zu ende gemacht hat ich sag
ich bin wahrscheinlich oder in einem vw
käfer gezeugt worden also auto war immer
in meinem leben da aber irgendwann habe
ich mich gefragt warum eigentlich
überall und sobald du das einmal gesehen
hast kannst du nicht an den schritt
zurück machen aber dieses verteufeln des
automobils per se ist etwas was mir
widerstrebt dicken nach mich tatsächlich
über menschen reden paternalistisches
verhalten und komplett fern ein dass wir
diesen quadrat von paris unterschrieben
haben
[Musik]
lutz katja herzlich willkommen auf
meiner couch
seid ihr hotel gekommen auf jeden fall
nutzt mit welchem seiner fünf autos bist
du da nein ich würde den flieger
gekommen noch besser und katja ich bin
mit der bahn mit der bahn wenn wir an
das wort auto denken was sind so bei
euch die ersten assoziationen die
aufkommen lutz autor in deinem kopf was
passiert da individualität
unabhängigkeit
bei schwachen angeboten von öpnv heraus
oder anderen verkehrsträgern sicherlich
eine vernünftige wahl noch heutzutage
katja du beim wort auto was sind deine
assoziation also gefragt sagt der
allerersten das ist für mich ein orange
vw käfer bei meiner eltern das war das
erste auto und da hatte ich immer
probleme mit meiner verdauung ich musste
nicht immer übergeben eine schnelle
vorrücken der eine gute beifahrerin die
hinten drin es ist auf jeden fall prägen
weil das war immer so teil unserer reise
sozusagen
ansonsten ist auto für mich etwas im
mobilitäts nichts möchte dass jeder sein
leben ohne auto gestalten kann in dem
sinne dass er kein auto mehr kaufen muss
sondern es vielleicht leid wenn es
brauch oder sie dann wäre jemand wie
lutz bald arbeitslos was macht das mit
dir wenn du das hörst nein das thema ich
finde es hochinteressant ich wäre ja
auch aus das verkehrsmittel wenn ich von
a nach b kommen was optimal für mich
passt sprich wenn ich von einer
großstadt zu anderen will wenn ich von
frankfurt nach stuttgart will nämlich
den ic sobald ich in den den urbanen
raum dort vor ort verlassen und muss in
den ländlichen raum dann wird es eben
schwierig mit den verbindungen gehen wir
ganz konkret aufs land katar du sprichst
mit menschen die autofahren zum teil
müssen und gar nicht wollen wie du sagst
nehmen wir die krankenschwester morgens
muss die um ich sag jetzt einfach 6 uhr
zur frühschicht antreten da fährt kein
bus und wenn dann müsste sie schon so
früh da im bus sitzen dass das kaum noch
im vertretbar wäre was machen wir mit dr
also ich kenne genau diese
krankenschwestern die im auto gerade
sitzen und die wird auch in meinem buch
vorkommen ich habe feuerwehrmänner alte
menschen die krankenschwester ärztin wie
auch immer die alleine ziehen ist
gefragt und sie sagt natürlich sich
gerade im auto natürlich ist gerade das
angebot nicht da und sie sagte für meine
zweijährige will ich sofort das auto
abschaffen und da ist für mich die frage
ist das gut also sie will ja nicht auto
fahren sie muss es um ihr leben zu
gestalten oder sollten wir heute
anfangen die alternativen zu schaffen
die ehe erlauben eben ohne auto
unterwegs sein bis hierhin seid ihr euch
sympathisch oder unsympathisch nicht
mehr zu entdecken aber couch sitzt man
ja normalerweise meistens nur mit
menschen die man einigermaßen kennt und
das habe ich schon gemerkt dass ich in
der situation an kommen musste weil
schon naht also ich finde ihn auch
sympathisch es geht ja nur darum dass
wir vielleicht heute einander
kennenlernen und auch wie wir so ticken
das machen wir genau jetzt und guck mal
wie lange ihr euch noch wie sympathisch
bleibt weil wir gehen ans eingemachte
und gucken uns mal aussagen an wo ich
mir vorstellen könnte dass ihr da doch
relativ weit auseinander steht aber ich
lasse mich gerne überraschen und wird
sagen wir bauen ein bisschen helfen wir
gerne mit die beiden sind sich noch viel
zu einig und ich glaube dass es erst mal
nur vorgetäuscht war in wirklichkeit
haben die ja komplett unterschiedliche
standpunkte und in der psychologie
liegen wer ist genauso was messbar zu
machen und deswegen habe ich jetzt eine
art barometer mitgebrachte mal zu gucken
wie sehr stimmt ihr bestimmten aussagen
zu gar nicht oder ganz fehlen diese
stange wenn wir uns jetzt vorstellen
wäre eine skala dann würden wir ganz
unten anfassen wenn wir sagen wir stehen
wir überhaupt nicht zu ganz anderer
meinung ich sage nein oder ganz oben
wenn ich sage ich stimme voll zu ja das
teile ich okay wir machen die probe um
zu gucken ob alles klar ist und zwar mit
folgender aussage andreas scheuer war
ein guter verkehrsminister
ich brauche nur eine hand hat mich klar
weiß wo du stehst soweit und ja noch
hält ich dann okay nehmen wir noch eine
guter nerven
dich nicht so sehr lutz deutlich mehr
okay und jetzt ans eingemachte
das generelle tempolimit auf autobahnen
ist der größte politisch seit dem
dosenpfand
katja sieht das ganz anders aus dutzend
tempolimit ich sehe dass einzelne
billige bei kostenloser maßnahmen und
wir müssen alles tun ok weit auseinander
franziska giffey über berlin eine 3,7
millionen stadt völlig autofrei zu
denken das ist für mich
wirklichkeitsfremd wieder ähnlich weit
auseinander wie ein tempolimit oder
kommt natürlich höher positive also für
mich ist das das vorstellbar weil
tatsächlich eine stadt wie berlin gute
wir sind ja auch gerade eine gute
versorgung hat und ich glaube wenn man
ohne visionen startet kommt man nicht
weit also man muss ja so anfangen das
vorzustellen weil sich das auf wir
müssen die ganze stadt autofrei denken
wenn du sagst du das ablichten wenn wir
ja so ein bisschen oder machen wir
nochmal heute der rücken macht so okay
da seid ihr jetzt ganz weit auseinander
heißt autofreie stadt keine option für
dich bis zu einem es wird nie eine
komplett autofrei staates den
krankenwagen deswegen ja dann waren
feuerwehrwagen das sowieso ja nur das
angebot muss stimmen und ich sehe im
augenblick in den nächsten zehn jahren
in egal in welcher stadt in deutschland
sehe ich nicht die möglichkeiten das den
leuten zu geben ja man kann auch
80-jährige oder 70 jährige nicht auf dem
scooter erstellen was wir jetzt wo er
gerade als wagen wir es gut funktioniert
einfach nicht also meine mutter wäre
nach drei metern verunglückt ja deswegen
also das ist sicherlich nicht möglich
fehlen die visionen ja das problem wir
haben verlernt zu träumen und träume die
die geben ja eine richtung vor und wenn
wir nicht träumen das ist autofrei geht
dann machen wir auch nix aber auf zehn
jahre ja aber zehn jahre auto vor sich
nicht nehmen wir die fahrräder das
lastenrad ist das arschgeweih des
alnatura adels meint zumindest die
weltpolitik redaktion das lastenrad
zitat mit dem besagten hirschgeweih ich
hatte es zuvor nicht gehört das hatten
wir ja einen schmunzeln natürlich auf
die lippen gezaubert muss aber sagen
manchmal muss man dinge auch
überzeichnen um eine reaktion und eine
wirkung zu erzielen so gesehen fand ich
das jetzt weniger schlimm als vielleicht
katja es empfunden hat katja gäste dann
noch in die knie oder ist das schon ja
ich das könnte auf den boden auf
schaufeln also das ist für mich was soll
das was ist das für ein bild was ist
denn dann der suv ist dass das
arschgeweih von wem auch immer ich finde
das immer sehr schwierig und ich selber
gebe zu ich habe ja auch vorurteile
gegen bestimmte autotypen wo ich lernen
musste das hat auch ein paar gründe also
deswegen zu sagen dass ein
transportmittel sagt wieder drin sitzt
das ist mir zu billig lastenräder ulkige
idee sagt christian lindner von der fdp
wie stets wieder zum thema wenn jetzt
familien damit ihre einkäufe erledigen
oder ihre kinder in die kita bringen ist
es dass eine können sie ja gerne machen
und muss man noch keinem vorschreiben
können sie auch machen das ist in
ordnung das allerdings einzusetzen
teilweise für lieferverkehr oder im
geschäftsleben habe ich bei einigen
kurierdiensten kann ich das auch noch
verstehen da sind ja heute auch noch
fahrradfahrer oder sind viele
fahrradfahrer unterwegs aber wenn ich
die abends sehe die bei uns mittlerweile
in großstädten essen liefern oder
ähnliches da haben wir das proletariat
der zukunft was ist heute los polizei
hat also ich nehme ja verdienende das
ist ja statistisches gelegt ich glaube
da bin ich jetzt einfach mal
selbstbewusst zu sagen ich bin näher
dran an den menschen weil ich mich dem
aussetzen das ist unterschiedliche
meinungen gibt dass es unterschiedliche
mobilitätsformen gibt und das ist etwas
mit dem proletariat da bin ich mit ihm
zusammen gezuckt ja ich sehe darin nicht
die lösung unserer mobilität oder
unserer lieferkette dann kommen wir
zurück zum großen thema autos spritpreis
hammer benzin kostet jetzt über zwei
euro
andreas scheuer sieht das bei bild als
katastrophal an und sagt da müssen wir
was tun bei zwei euro muss die politik
einschreiten und schlägt dann vor
steuern runter damit es nicht noch
teurer wird was haltet ihr davon
volle zustimmung bei lutz matthias koch
davon noch zu schaufeln dann du zuerst
das ist doch einfach
dieses dieses so so tun als ob das auto
nicht so funktioniert es von vorne bis
hinten dienstwagenprivileg diese
privilegien alle möglichen dinge die den
autoverkehr auch stützen und fördern wir
wollen sogar noch 850 gesamte autobahn
bauen und wenn jetzt der treibstoff
teurer wird dann ist es nur ein zeichen
der zeit dass wir was verändern müssen
bei den treibstoff stellen ja nicht
hierher sie sind ja abhängig von anderen
dienste liefern und wenn das dann einen
weltmarkt situationen gibt wo der preis
auch steigt dann ist das so nutzt du
springst andreas scheuer sofort bei uns
sagt volle zustimmung bei zwei wochen
muss schluss sein es gibt länder in
denen zahlt man 20 30 40 cent den liter
wir zahlen bei uns zwei euro jetzt was
dann als absolut aktuell autofahren wird
bei uns in deutschland vor allem durch
den staat extrem teuer gemacht wir haben
sehr viele abgaben wir haben gestiegene
kfz-steuern die krankenschwester oder
jeder der draußen fährt und das ist das
was andy schneider mit meinte diese
leute auch zu entlasten das ist das
thema dann bei der bambus stange war das
natürlich ein interessante übung weil
wir einander sehr nahe war körperlich
aber natürlich in den köpfen so weit
auseinander und ich glaube das war auch
ein gutes mittel um aufzuzeigen wenn
rein von den abmaßen wo gibt wer von uns
eigentlich hier nicht glaube wir waren
uns bei fast gar nichts einig die hände
sind am schluss nah beieinander obwohl
ich das gefühl habe wir stehen dann ganz
mit punkten weit auseinander übergibt
die mir die stange wieder vielen dank
und dann würde ich sagen zurück auf die
couch das waren jetzt klare meinungen
absichtlich auch ein stückweit
provoziert dass wir die unterschied
einmal sehen ich bin absolut zufrieden
mit der stange weil ich glaube die schön
aufgemacht hat was hier für
meinungsunterschiede sind und die
brauchen wir jetzt für die weitere
diskussion
was hatte ich am meisten überrascht wir
waren bei einigen themen vorher dichter
beieinander durch diese aussagen hat
sich wieder etwas weiter entfernt ich
glaube nur dass wir teilweise andere
kenntnis haben andere daten kennen
beispielsweise
ja schön mit der krankenschwester die
wir immer wieder kommen auf dem land was
er gesagt hat es dort ist eine bahnlinie
geplant gewesen es gibt ja auch viele
stillgelegte bahn linien sondern wenn
man die wieder in betrieb nehmen würde
ja schöne idee aber die sind nicht
elektrifiziert und dann fährst wieder
mit der diesellok ja und das ist halt
das deswegen bin ich sehr skeptisch weil
es immer heißt na ja das haben wir in
fünf jahren und ich habe vielleicht zu
wenig fantasie zu wenig fantasie ist das
was euch vielleicht und zentral
unterscheidet dass du sagst ich habe
visionen ich habe ideen ich habe
fantasien die eine ganz andere ich weiß
nicht ob uns das unterscheidet ich habe
ein sehr klares bild also ich könnte dir
sehr lange erzählen wie die welt für
mich aussieht und ich wenn wir jetzt bei
statistiken sind wenn das doch so
wichtig ist mit dem auto warum sitzen
dann nur 45 minuten am tag gefahren mit
13 personen also ich glaube wir müssen
einfach ran an diese autos die halt
nicht genutzt werden das sehe ich habe
mir selber die sind mit blinden scheiben
teilweise in dem wohnviertel warum
stehen überall die plätze voll wo
gastronomie sein könnte kinder spielen
könnte usw würdest du denn deinen
geliebten porsche stehen lassen und bus
fahren wenn ich wie gesagt nicht
anderthalb stunden morgens ins büro
unterwegs wäre ich gar kein problem
damit ich sehe dich nicht im bus naja
kommt drauf haben wir noch drin sitzen
dann schreib paula
und punkt und deutschen sagt man ja
gerne nach wir sind nicht so die
emotionalen typen aber wenn es ums auto
geht ist das ganz anders da gab es eine
große umfrage 2009 10 unter 1000 haltern
und die zeigt 75% behandeln ihr auto wie
einen guten kumpel 40 prozent reden
sogar mit ihm und dann geht es weiter
wir schreiben unseren autos menschliche
eigenschaften zu wir glauben dass es
genießt wenn wir es waschen putzen
pflegen und manche sagen sogar das auto
ihres brauch mitleid bei technischen
schwierigkeiten hier wird klar wenn wir
so eine emotionale verbindung zum auto
wieso die emotionen so hochkochen wenn
wir drüber streiten
das angebot da ist verändert verändert
sich verhalten das ist ja das problem
dass viele leute nicht haben die fühlen
sich der situation wie es heute ist auf
dem land zum beispiel ausgeliefert und
ich habe so viele leute gesprochen bei
denen das der fall ist und mir gesagt
haben du bist die erste die mir ob die
frage stellt willst du oder musst du
auto fahren ich muss autofahrern die mir
gesagt weil er nichts ist und das kann
auch nicht sein dass wir so ein
hochentwickeltes land und sowas nicht
hinbekommen kommt es da wird auch in 20
jahren nicht sein weil es kein mensch
bezahlen kann katja das ist noch nicht
mal böser wille ist kann kein mensch
bezahlen es fällt immer noch auf das die
beiden extrem höflich sind und ihre
klaren position nicht wirklich benennen
und deswegen machen wir jetzt etwas das
man in der psychologie schild entdeckt
man nennt das bedeutet ich werde zum
schild zwischen den beiden das heißt der
eine kann voll raushauen gegen nicht das
schild während die andere person zu
hören muss aber passiv ohne direkt
reagieren zu können und dadurch können
sachen nach vorne kommen die man sich
vielleicht sonst nicht trauen würde zu
sagen also mir wäre lieb wenn lutz sich
nicht nur um seine klientel kümmert
sondern hat um alle die in deutschland
leben mir wäre lieb wenn er zulässt dass
andere menschen vielleicht auch
mobilitätsbedürfnisse haben die nicht im
auto liegen dass wir einfach technik und
mensch sehen und nicht nur technik als
ich vorne saß und hat ja
sprach hätte ich gerne ihr gesicht dabei
auch mal gesehen hast du hast ja einen
vorsitzenden von einem der größten
deutschen autoclub sitzen was gibst du
dir mit tempolimit tatsächlich das ist
etwas da bin ich was erstaunt dass wir
das nicht hinbekommen als einziges land
in europa haben wir das noch nicht
autobahn landstraße und in der stadt hat
andere geschwindigkeiten zu etablieren
dass der verkehrsfluss verbessert wird
das die emissionen sinken und das
menschenleben gerettet werden lutz
kompletter gegen was schleusers zudem
entgegen ich kann eigentlich nur
statistiken schleudern also es gibt für
mich beim tempolimit kein argument es
weiter zu behalten außer ich will aber
doch ich hätte da sicherlich gerne zum
ein oder anderen vielleicht stellungen
gehören gern dazu ja das hätte ich gerne
getan genug ans ja ich glaube das ist
lorenz ist er etwas das kann ich von mir
auch wenn man wenn man in der eigenen
welt ist und denkt ich bin der maßstab
und andere menschen nicht kennt also ich
habe zum beispiel in verwandten verloren
durch er zu hohe geschwindigkeit einer
gegenseite
dann ist das etwas was ein vielleicht
nicht so
präsent ist was man ja auch gewinnt wenn
man bestimmte sachen einfach mal
limitiert die freiheit von mir endet
dort wo die freiheit anderer beginnt
dann tauschen noch einmal durch und guck
mal was nutzt nur für dich raus haut
vielen dank hat ja
jetzt du trittst du das menschliche
schutzschilde nimmt ihr platz und weiß
um die position von katja ich glaube
zwar nicht genervt sondern er hat er
manchmal keine lust zu zuhören weil er
wahrscheinlich bestimmte sachen die ich
gebracht habe auch erwartet hat weil sie
ja nur fakten sind und weil er glaube
ich auch manchmal das gefühl hatte ob
das stimmt steht auf den anderen zettel
dass ich mich mit der wissenschaft und
bestimmten statistiken nicht so
auskennen gerade was ich auch immer das
thema unfalltote ansprach kann ich nur
ganz klar sagen es tut mir leid um den
den sie verloren hat aus ihrer familie
aber wenn sich sagt das war eine
überhöhte geschwindigkeit der gegenseite
dann gehe ich mal davon aus dass sogar
ein tempolimit geherrscht hat und das
auf einer landstraße passiert ist
aktuell ist es so dass deutschlands
autobahnen im jahr
unter 300
tote überhaupt nur zu beklagen haben das
heißt einer pro tag meistens sogar oder
ein großteil sogar selbstmörder ist ganz
furchtbar wir haben dort kein problem
wir haben ein problem auf landstraßen
und wir haben ein problem in der stadt
und müssen nicht irgendein nebelkerzen
zünden was die autobahn betrifft ich
fand es schlimm zu sagen es gibt ja nur
einen toten am tag das sind meistens
auch suizidale
geisterfahrer in weil ich glaube
tatsächlich dass jeder jedes leben ist
ja etwas wert und dean er uns dieses
leben rückt in dem hat vielleicht auch
menschen sterben die wir kennen desto
real wird es dann ja auch thema klima da
werdet ihr wahrscheinlich auch ziemlich
weit auseinander liegen was würdest du
katja da wieder das thema wie gesagt
fuels die kann man auch klimaneutral wie
gesagt herstellen und man könnte sie wie
gesagt in ländern wie nordafrika
herstellen und hätten dabei sogar noch
geopolitisch noch was tolles geleistet
sprich diese leute würden nicht mehr zu
uns strömen die ihre länder verlassen
sondern sie hätten plötzlich arbeit sie
hätten wohlstand sie würden sich nicht
mehr die köpfe einschlagen was wir ja
oft genug eben erleben und hätten dort
mal knallhart gesagt die zweite emirate
am ende es ist wirklich was ich
betroffen macht so ein menschenbild zu
haben weil die menschen die jetzt
flüchten machen dass oftmals sich aus
finanziellen gründen sondern weil
entweder kriege in den ländern herrschen
weil bestimmte bevölkerungsgruppe
unterdrückt werden oder eben weil der
klimawandel die klimakrise sie aus den
ländern drängt und diese treibstoffe
kann man nicht nur in autos sondern auch
in andere große verkehrsträger wie
containerschiffe und ähnliches eben
einsätzen in dem moment jetzt getrennt
durch schild wohl lutz katja nicht mehr
sehen kann kann man zum ersten mal in
ihrem gesicht lesen was in ihrem kopf
vor sich geht das plötzlich viel mehr
mimik vielmehr reaktionen das hatten wir
vorher nicht also wir werden es nicht
schaffen die klimaziele von paris glaube
ich nur durch eben mobilität die bis
2030 darzustellen definitiv nicht katja
setzt sich ein für eine verkehrswende
ganz zentral was stört mich am meisten
an ihrer position mich stört daran dass
sie immer glaubt dass autofahren den
leuten doch nicht die individuelle
mobilität bringt die sie benötigen
kommen wir wieder zu dem thema die leute
fahren wie sie sagt nur ungern auto die
sie teilweise interviewt hat ja das mag
sein auf der einen seite haben sie keine
alternative aber ich glaube wir haben
ein problem zwischen
großstädten oder urbanen flächen und sag
ich mal gebieten wie der eifel dem
bayerischen wald
bestimmten vom vogtland oder ähnlichem
da kannst du mit nichts anderem fahren
da bist du dann zu hause eingeschlossen
vielen dank jetzt haben wir hier die
dynamik die die ganze zeit schon da war
aber nicht nach vorne gekommen ist und
durch das schutzschild haben sie zum
ersten mal spüren können katja gab es
momente wo sich seine mimik stark
verändert hat bei lutz aussagen bestimmt
also ich besser selber unter kontrolle
wenn man sich unbeobachtet fühlt ich
habe manchmal so ein bisschen das gefühl
wir müssen alle aus unseren komfortzonen
raus also ich muss einen schritt auf
lutz zugehen umgekehrt aber auch die
wahrheit ist manchmal auch einfach in
der mitte sowie es klassisch ist im
leben und da er ist auf jeden fall auch
jemand der offener ist aber das finde
ich anerkennenswert und gut dass wir
heute sitzen und uns ausliefern ist
heute los war auch mal ein gedanke da
war ja gesagt warum dann nicht da also
das war auch dass ich sage ich dahin
wohl gleich zusammen irgendein orangenen
käfer steigt würde ich euch jetzt bitte
einmal aufzustehen und vor die tafel zu
steigen und dann nehmen wir eine
komplett neue perspektiven auf das was
wir gerade machen was wir hier machen
nennt sich metern euro klingt erst mal
kompliziert ist aber ganz einfach wir
machen eine art zusätzliche ebene auf
und versuchen zu spiegeln was ihr auf
der couch passiert ist weil wenn man so
im eifer des gefechts im konflikt in der
diskussion steckt dann vergisst man
vielleicht manchmal wie gehen wir
überhaupt miteinander um und dann so ein
schritt raus zu machen und von außen auf
sich selbst zu gucken und mal zu
reflektieren was passiert da eigentlich
kann extrem hilfreich sein um für die
weitere diskussion vielleicht eine neue
ebene aufzumachen ich höre ich erst mal
einfach nur zu und ihr besprechen wie
die beiden bisher miteinander umgehen
von außen auf uns schauen gern dazu auch
näher aneinander stellen ich bin das ist
immer ganz interessant wenn man so auf
situationen schaut weil man dann ja gar
nicht unbedingt auf inhalte schaut
sondern eher auf dem herrn ismen und
auch wie in einer diskussion miteinander
umgegangen wird was meter über der couch
schwebt ist natürlich dass lutz insofern
die einfachere position hat weil der
status quo bewahrt also etwas was sehr
vertraut ist was alle leute kennen was
was auch so gelebt ist und ich bin
die manchmal immer wieder an die
phantasie adressieren muss weil ich halt
eine welt aufmachen möchte die sich
verändert ich glaube dass noch mal auf
die couch gucken sich selbst noch mal
sehen und bewerten sowie den anderen
protagonisten ich glaube das war die
schwerste geschichte ja also ich sehe
teilweise bei
katja das thema das sie sicherlich
einiges umkrempeln will vielleicht auch
grundlegende aber das teilweise
bestimmte technische oder
wissenschaftliche möglichkeiten leider
außer acht gelassen werden ja ja der
mann den raum gestellt dass ich
angeblich amtliche statistiken
nichtkenner dass ich irgendwelche fakten
nicht kennt dass ich das ganze
brimborium mit ihr fühlen sich kenner
stimmt natürlich nicht ich glaube an
diese lösung nicht ganz so einfach wir
machen jetzt von links nach rechts oder
von einer farbe zu anderen von schwarz
nachweis wird zeit leider nicht gehen
das war so etwas paternalistisch also
ein bisschen da kommst du auch noch hin
mädchen verhalten halt mir fest so
nimmst du katja war ganz einfach schwarz
oder weiß von links nach rechts in dem
streit ist bei einigen gingen ja
wie streitet lutz ich glaube lutz
streitet
schon offen und da ist auch für neues
zugänglich aber zum einen versucht er
bestimmte dinge auch eben die leute
draußen etwas haben zu bewahren in ihrer
mobilität und auf der anderen seite aber
auch den weg zu neuen dingen vielleicht
auch das sehr extrem was bestimmte
wissenschaftliche themen betrifft
anzugehen katja wenn du dir anschaust
wäre das ein streit etwas gefällt dir
besonders an ihm und seinem diskutieren
dass er hat sehr klar verankert ist dass
das das seinen standpunkt auch klar ist
und er dann auch klar adressiert und
wenn du auf dich selber guckt was
würdest du sagen das mag ich an meinem
die neugier glaube ich also das den
staat ist kurz hinterfragen zu fragen
woher kommt das eigentlich dass es so
ist wie es heute ist und was könnten die
ableitung sein für eine gute zukunft für
alle was magst du nicht an der katheter
selbst ich bin oftmals diejenige die
natürlich nicht nur ein hauptsatz sagen
kann sondern ich muss
selbst erklären was ich meine weiß noch
nicht da ist und das ist etwas was ich
durchaus mag aber auch als anstrengend
mal dich raus sitzt er da sitzt guck dir
nochmal an stellen dir vor was magst du
an seiner art vielleicht nicht so ganz
in diesem diskurs
ist kurz das ist vielleicht manchmal
ungeduldig bin weil ich vielleicht auch
bestimmte dinge voraussetze
oder weil man einen anderen
kenntnisstand hat
und des menschen nämlich da ein bisschen
dann ja unruhig macht warum wissen die
das nicht oder warum haben wir das
vorher nicht oder warum die ist das
gelesen oder e-mails gelesen deswegen
nimmst du den lutz ungeduldig war
also ich glaube man kann ihn klar folgen
also ich bin word und excel also das ist
halt irgendwie so relativ klar für mich
dass ich natürlich er die prosa bin und
er ist jemand der sehr stark mit
statistiken sich auskennen und ich bin
eher so der menschliche faktor in den
ardennen soll der der menschen die nicht
auto fahren vielleicht also das ist so
ein will was ich gerade habe wenn ihr
beiden bis hierhin noch mal auf eure
diskussion auf eure couch guckt seid ihr
zufrieden bis hierhin ja auch mit den
beiden ja setzen so wunderbar da wollen
wir jetzt mal gucken was passiert wenn
wir jetzt mal einen wirklich drastischen
perspektivwechsel reinnehmen okay wir
haben reflektiert wir haben so viele
unterschiedliche standpunkte gehört und
doch immer wieder gemerkt wir haben es
hier mit argumentation profis zu tun die
ihre punkte schon in ganz verschiedenen
lagern immer und immer wieder genannt
haben und deswegen breche ich das jetzt
auf und die beiden tauschen die rollen
lutz wird zu katja katja wird zur lutz
und dann halten sie jeweils eine rede
die sie so noch nie gehalten haben die
bühne ist deine und es gibt noch eine
wichtige information wir sind auf der
jahreshauptversammlung
weihnachtsfeier von drei jahren
europameister her ja ich hab
jahreshauptversammlung glück ist jetzt
live linden bei der
jahreshauptversammlung vom automobilclub
von deutschland und ganz wichtig muss
sein publikum natürlich überzeugen mit
den punkten die luchse machen würde das
publikum ist das was da auch
normalerweise sitzen würde und eine
gemeinheit gibt es noch du musst so
lange überzeugen bis lust sich zu einem
applaus hingerissen fühlt um dich aus
dieser situation
zeigt uns jetzt dass du lutz argumente
und punkte rund um das thema auto flug
oder freiheit verstanden hast bitte
schön die rede die katja dann quasi mit
meiner figur gehalten hat
hat sicherlich einige elemente enthalten
die klassisch für solche veranstaltungen
sind einer jahreshauptversammlung aber
sie hat natürlich schon ein bisschen
herein gestartet und nach dem motto
werden vielleicht wenige weibliche
teilnehmer bei uns sehr geehrte herren
meine wenigen damen ich begrüße sie
heute bei unserer hauptversammlung vom
avd und ich kann ihnen sagen ich habe
gutes in meinem gepäck an die scheuer
hat für unsere zulieferindustrie eine
milliarde euro freigegeben das zeigt wir
sind auf dem richtigen weg wir sind eine
industrie die ernst genommen wird wir
sind auch ein verband der ernst genommen
wird auto mobilität bedeutet freiheit
auto mobilität bedeutet das leben so zu
gestalten wie wir es wollen und ich
glaube wir als verband haben uns hier
sehr gut platziert wir haben auch die
eingabe petition gegen die eur 7 normen
gemacht wir zeigen dass wir nicht alles
mit uns machen lassen wir sind nicht nur
industrievertreter sondern auch
vertreter für ganz viele menschen die
heute auto fahren denn wir wissen alle
deutschland ist nun mal ein land mit
einer schlüsselindustrie die das auto
voran bringt die auch weiterhin das auto
voranbringen wird das zeigen die
exportzahlen und ich denke hier sind wir
diejenigen die die stimme nach außen
sind für unsere mitglieder wir haben
vielleicht
eine sequenz gehört von er in der sie
dann auch sagt wir sind
industrievertreter das hat mich ein
bisschen geärgert weil das sind wir
nicht wir lassen sie uns doch einfach
mal hinschauen wie war es denn im
bundestagswahlkampf da waren die grünen
mit dieser irren idee der lastenrad
prämie für 1000 euro wer will denn
lastenrad frauen wenn ein schönes auto
fahren kann und damit auch einen eigenen
bereich für sich hat jenseits von arbeit
und zuhause katja kann ja mal eben aus
der hüfte und auch rhetorisch brillant
raushauen was nutzt argumente sind aber
man merkt ja auch an dass sie das
vielleicht nicht hundertprozentig gerne
macht weil so ein bisschen muss sie
ironisch sarkastisch bleiben um nicht
ganz los rolle anzunehmen also
tatsächlich dafür dass es zu spontanen
war glaube ich war echt okay da bin ich
auch zufrieden mit aber es war halt
schon interessant das hat überhaupt
nicht geklappt stadt also ich denke hier
wir sind eine stimme die es braucht sie
sind eine laute stimme werden
wahrgenommen und weiterhin werden wir
wahrgenommen werden denn wir vertreten
diese deutschen menschen etwa sie nicht
weiter da kriegst wir sehen hier auch
nur genießen und denkt die ganze zeit
gibt's schon szenenapplaus klein als
dass ich nicht die ganze zeit also
rhetorischer wohl bis zur außer brillant
ja ich habe versucht das beste daraus zu
machen
hatte ja nun aufmerksam ihren
argumenten gelauscht wie gut es mir
gelungen ist oder nicht das müsst ihr
bewerten oder die zuschauer oder katja
also und jetzt müsst ihr euch bei einmal
fragen wie viel fantasie wir uns
zutrauen entweder wir nehmen von mir aus
die eröffnung der autofreien innenstadt
hamburg du als katja ist lang das
gefällt mir schlicht sonst hätte ich
noch eine schippe drauflegen eröffnung
der autofreien a7 riesen 3000 leute die
dir jubelnd nach all den jahren kampf
das mussten wir das autofreie hamburg
war dass die autofreie innenstadt
hamburg haben wir die autofreie
innenstadt ja man geht ja
alle zehn tage oder eine woche auf dem
podium aber
hat ja meistens nun seinen part und sein
blickwinkel und seine welt die man dort
vertritt deswegen ist es nur etwas
ungewohnt daneben wenn man die rolle
dort wechselt ja liebe bürger der stadt
hamburg und bürgerinnen herzlich
willkommen bei der eröffnung der
autofreien innenstadt hamburg wir haben
unser ziel erreicht mehr lebensqualität
für bürger und bürgerinnen in dieser
stadt zu erreichen der ausbau der
radwege ist immens vorangeschritten und
es ist kaum zu glauben wir haben es auch
geschafft den ländlichen bereich an den
öpnv weiter anzuschließen und damit
hervorragende verbindungen von der
fläche in die stadt hamburg zu erreichen
so dass auch die menschen hier an
kulturellen leben in hamburg sowie auch
an ausbildungen und fortbildungen
teilhaben zu können wir haben neue
subventionen für lasten fahrräder nicht
die angestrebten 1000 euro der grünen in
der letzten wahl sondern wir haben es
aus zweieinhalbtausend geschafft sie
wissen ja die meisten lastenräder liegen
ja teilweise bei 5000 euro im schnitt
lutz hat offenbar gemerkt dass katja
eben an manchen stellen soll ein
bisschen ironisch war und lässt es sich
jetzt nicht nehmen zu kontern die autos
sind aus der stadt verschwunden wir
haben jetzt neue park and ride system
am stadtrand errichten können busse
fahren im fünf-minuten-takt
selbstverständlich elektro oder mit öl
betrieben tatsächlich habe ich mir
gedacht ich glaube schon länger nicht
weil ich wollte dann bild wissen und des
weiteren
auch die
fleht fahrten und alster fahrten werden
elektrisch vorgenommen also ist es viel
angekommen sagen wir so also die
kommunikation hat auf jeden fall in dem
sinne funktioniert dass er versteht was
das zielbild vielleicht auch wein kann
man
kennt sich sehr gut aus in hamburg ja
ich mag städte die am wasser liegen und
das andere wir bleiben da war bevor ich
jetzt hier mit irgendwelchen
lokalpatriotismus wieder zusammenfindet
erstmal inhaltlich hat er dich abgeholt
ja also ich fand das insofern spannend
weil er diese bilder ja anscheinend auch
im kopf hat die ich habe wo ich so gerne
daran arbeiten wollen würde jetzt müssen
wir das so sagen er ist ja gerade katja
ich gehe hier als deckel und halten
daraus wenn er so weiter macht dass wir
nicht riskieren schulnote für diese rede
befriedigt los er forderte ein die
beiden vielen dank kommt noch mal
zusammen auf die couch jetzt hatten wir
mit der rede noch einmal die
konfrontation und beide sitzen jetzt
auch wieder so ein bisschen distanziert
auseinander ich habe aber die ganze zeit
den eindruck dass hier eigentlich
potenzial für gegenseitige wertschätzung
drinsteckt und deswegen hole ich die
beiden jetzt nochmal maximal nahe
zusammen ich würde ich wirklich gerne zu
ehrlich auch egal welche rolle jeweils
zeit auch wenn wir sie mal tauschen da
war gab ja so viel drin und auch soviel
wo man merkt das sind verständnis da ist
zurück in euren eigentlichen rollen lutz
als lutz katja als katja tut mir den
gefallen zum finale reicht euch einmal
die hände beide
eine ende beide ende ich fand's super
schrecken fremden mann so lange die
hände zu geben das hat aber nichts zu
tun dass man macht man sowas schon mal
als familie total schräg sagt euch doch
bitte gegenseitig abwechselnd
wertschätzende punkte die am anderen
nicht nur inhaltlich sondern auch im
umgang heute sagt aber eben beides
inhaltlich und wie miteinander
diskutiert und hier heute auf der couch
gearbeitet wurde
ich habe kein problem gehabt mit katja
jetzt soweit händchen zu halten wie ihr
das dann alles aufgezeichnet hab
also ich etwas was auch schon gesagt
wurde die respektvolle art ich hatte
auch das gefühl dass uns aussprechen
gegenseitig ich hatte das gefühl auf
augenhöhe
gelegentlich manchmal hasses verlassen
wenn es um zahlen ging da fühlte ich
manchmal so ein bisschen das so da nicht
denkt sie sind auf augenhöhe
aber mir gefallen dass wir so offen uns
ausgetauscht haben und jeder von uns
glaube ich mal platzieren konnte was im
kopf ist nutzt die fed werde ich auch
was in städten also das eine was sie
schon gleich am anfang gesagt das ist
hatte ich ja wohl noch genannt die
respektvolle umgang miteinander
vernünftiges diskutieren ja auch dass
das offen sein für für andere argumente
oder es auch durchaus mal verstehen dass
es auch eine andere sichtweise gibt es
war das was ich eigentlich hier somit
nehme jetzt man sieht sofort dass das
für die gerade sehr ungewohnt ist so zu
sitzen und so zu reden kann ich gut
nachvollziehen aber ich glaube dass hier
jetzt noch mal wunderschön klar wird
dass die auch ganz viel teilen und
vielleicht sogar eine gemeinsame vision
haben können genug wertschätzung jeweils
füreinander
[Musik]
wenn ihr jetzt sagt das viel ebenso als
idee ihr beide zusammen als team in die
politik was verändern oder überhaupt
sich zusammentun und was zu verändern wo
würdet ihr an setzten den gedanken habe
ich echt genießen weil wir ins
verkehrsministerium gehen und sagen wir
beide erzählen euch mal was ich glaube
tatsächlich das ist ein kracher
überraschungsmoment wäre weil ich glaube
trotz allem dass wir so unterschiedliche
herangehensweisen haben ergänzen sicher
bestimmte dinge es muss eine veränderung
geben müssen wir gestalten und da kann
vielleicht leute
wie lutz und ich verschiedene gruppen
auch mal zusammen führen also dass man
nicht immer nur übereinander redet
sondern auch da miteinander redet aber
ich glaube also den gedanken war ich
echt genießen weil wir jetzt
verkehrsministerium gehen und sagen wir
beide erzählen euch mal was das wäre
glaube ich schon eine überraschung ja
ich glaube das steht vielleicht ja sogar
bevor er vielleicht sogar schneller als
wir glauben ja
zumindest politisch wandern richtung
haaransatz nein nein nein ich meine das
ganz ernst ich meine das was gerade dort
passiert fdp spricht mit mit grünen ja
also die ganz große bühne zusammen
gekommen auf der couch heute wer weiß
vielleicht im kleinen hier und da drüben
im großen die beiden jetzt zum abschluss
wünschte ich mir und da müsst ihr noch
helfen die lücke zu füllen ein gefährt
auf den ihr beide zusammen richtung
sonnenuntergang in die zukunft was wäre
das
ich glaube wir gehen zu fuß oder zu
fuß oder ein ewig betriebene
das nochmal kommt habe ich mir jetzt
hast gedacht gab ich ihm betriebene e
scooter sowas in der art ja okay wer
steht vorne
also dann lieber lutz dann lieber lutz
kannst dich nicht verstecken es wird auf
jeden fall fahren ist wird sie mein
gehirn einbrennen vielen dank ihr beide
dass sie wenn ihr auf der couch schwarz
danke dir dein gelernt alles gute weiter
ich habe das sehr genossen gemeinsam mit
katja leon auf der couch es war sehr
informativ manchmal auch kontrovers aber
immer sehr respektvoll und muss sagen ja
hat sich gelohnt ehrlich gesagt das
format total gut weil es zeit beide
seiten zwingt einen dazu zu hören das
natürlich super war die rede und ich bin
hier auch mal draußen weil ich weiß
jetzt auch was bewegt katja oder was
bewegt vielleicht katjas umfeld man muss
immer auch wissen was was andere leute
denken sie vielleicht eine ganz andere
meinung zu diesen themen haben
tatsächlich fällig das habe ich ja
vorhin abgesagt ist ein
überraschungsmoment schon cool weil das
sind ja allianzen die gibt es ja
momentan noch überhaupt nicht und ich
glaube tatsächlich dass wir auch
theoretisch sogar papier machen könnten
wo er seine dinge platzierter lust und
ich meine und dass wir vielleicht da
auch gar nicht so auseinander sind wenn
er seine aachen gewartet diese sitzung
heute war aus meiner sicht ein voller
erfolg und das lag an den beiden die
trauen sich hierhin mit zwei meinungen
die erstmal überhaupt nicht
zusammenpassen diskutieren dann aber in
einer art und weise und auch so
wertschätzend miteinander
dass ich am ende das gefühl hatte die
sind nicht nur aufeinander zugegangen
sondern daraus könnte wirklich was
konstruktives entstehen das war auf der
couch die diskussion geht unten in den
kommentaren weiter was denkst du beim
thema auto ist das für dich noch der
große traum von freiheit und
individualität oder sagst du keinen bock
mehr auf autos die müssen raus aus den
städten und fürs klima brauchen wir
sowieso weniger autos ich freue mich auf
die diskussion und sagt jetzt schon
danke für ein like für das video und
vielleicht hast du ja sogar lust diesen
kanal zu abonnieren dann weist als
erstes bescheid wenn es neue folgen gibt
bis dahin